hello everyone and welcome back to the
fie diagram 3 2019 again it's the battle
between Alexander Grishka anxious to do
that this time with the white pieces as
you know two of the classical games have
been drawn and then Duda takes the lead
by winning the first game of the rapid
this is the second game of the rapids
and if Grisha does not want to be
eliminated from the feeder Grand Prix
well from losing the finals he has to
retaliate in this game so he has the
white pieces it's all it's all up to him
so let's see let's see what happened in
the second rapid game Grisha with the
white pieces opens with d4 and okay we
have Knight to f6 c4 now we have East
six Knight to f3 and now not d5 here we
don't have the Queens gambit declined
rather b6 the Queen's Indian defense it
seems that that young do though is not
discouraged by all you know alpha zero
trash-talking the Queen's Indian defense
okay with g3 and the bishop to a6
attacking the c4 pawn with b3 defending
it and now Bishop to b4 check with the
shove the d2 defending and now push from
the back to e7 as you usually do in the
Queen's Indian defense with bishop the
g2 and now d5 both players Castle we
have castles by greenshoe castles by
Judah and now Knight to e5 and excellent
square a nice central outpost for
tonight not allowing knight c6 as the
night covers that square if Knight d7
you can just go knight c6 attack the
Queen and the bishop so just an
excellent square for the knight with c6
by black and Bishop to c3 the knight is
now on a the bishop is now on a very
useful diagonal we have night after d7
offering a trade of night and here there
are a few new moves in the position see
capture son d5 is a non Moon Knight the
d2 is a non move just capture sin b7 is
a non move but Knight back to d3 is not
unknown move and it is as a movie Levin
that we have a completely new game now I
think in all the games between Duda and
Grisha it's been like movie 11 or move
12 was a you know a completely new game
so that could be saying something or not
you know but okay a completely new game
and the do that goes for D captures in
c4 we have night the b4 now attacking
the bishop seemingly
fighting the point but not really
because after night captures and night
captures the c6 bone will be undefended
and also at the point is under attack
now so you have to play something with C
capture son b3 by Duda now allowing
allowing either characters the bishop on
e6 or perhaps you could even capture on
c6 Grisha goes for Knight characters we
have Knight captures and now Bishop
captures which comes with an attack on
the rook and here rook to b8 dooda dooda
goes rook to b8 roof to see it seems to
be somewhat stronger as it forces the
bishop to retreat would rook to b8 he
basically gives the grease sugar free
move which British uses very wisely he
plays a character son b3 grabs a pawn
and opens up an attack against the night
here and now after night the b4 as you
have to move it night before we have
Bishop character son before Bishop
captures and now just rook captures and
a7 and now after all is said and done
and Grisha ends up being up upon so what
what happens here the the knight is
under attack you have to do something
about that we have Knight to f6 and now
III strengthening the chain here and
here from this moment on English will be
enjoying his extra pawn and here do the
admits that rook to b8 was not was not a
great move he moves the rook all the way
to see it and now but should be back to
g2 we've looked yet preparing rook to e7
to trade the trade off a pair of rooks
and now Knight to e2 agree she starts
developing the night bringing it into
the game rookie 7 with rook captures and
now Bishop captures on e7 and not Knight
to c4 an excellent square for tonight
also pressuring the b6 pawn there could
be ideas like Queen a1 queen maybe
somewhere around there you know to
threaten the b6 pawn bishop back to f8
not wanting the bishop on e7 to stay a
target as like we mentioned this could
be an idea with with a double attack on
the phone and on the bishop so the
bishop will be safer there
Queen to a-1 by Gary shock and now b5
pushing the night either
well backward forward Knights the e5 by
agree shock and now comes Queen to b6
just keeping everything in order Duda
needs a draw and he wins the feeder
grand prix
look the c1 very shocked as do this back
rank is pretty weak agreeable of course
who wants to take advantage of that we
have route captures on c1 Queen captures
on c1 and now Queen to e7 asking what do
you want to play but Grisha is not
afraid of any Queen to a one checking
radius so he just plays Queen to c8 and
here he has he has a lot of really
interesting ideas one of them being well
if the Queen just remains there Bishop
the c6 followed by Bishop te8 followed
by Bishop captures on e7 check that that
just seems like a very nice maneuver
I might even use this as a thumbnail
we'll see how it goes but here do that
instead well you could go Queen a1 check
it is possible but there's no merit to
it for example but from the blocks and
now you don't have time for 94-92 and
captures on f1 because 97 just wins on
the spot there's no no countering this
so after and if you defend with Quint a3
yes that is possible but then just
Bishop captures here you lose the pawn
and you can never move the Queen from
the defense of the f8 bishop so after
Queen to c8 Duda played before but b4 is
not not a very useful move and also it
just takes away one of the squares from
which the Queen is able to defend the
bishop on f8 so here Sasha plays a very
interesting move and well feel free to
pause the video and try to find which is
this move that wins the game for forget
oak in this position well I give you a
couple of seconds for those of you who
were able to do it congratulations on
finding such such an intriguing move and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
no it's not the move we mentioned it's
not Bishop to c6 if the c6 then then
there is time if you want to avoid this
there's time you can go Bishop to Bishop
to g6 and then sorry you can just play
g6 create some breathing room for the
king and now if you play this then the
knight just captures it and the f7 point
is nicely defended so there's no problem
there the real move is Bishop the b7
this is the point that Greece should
made and now the threat is just horrible
Queen to c7 followed by Queen cap
of seven and there's no defending that
especially since there's no way to
defend the bishop as you'll see Duda
tried he prevented Queen to c7 with
Queen to a one check King g2 and now
Queen to a5 guarding the c7 square but
only now that the Queen moved from sort
of defending the f7 pawn now Bishop to
c6 and now this threat is very strong
Queen back to a7 do the says nope we're
keeping an eye on that but now it's
different now Bishop the e8 comes and
black lost a very important tempo
because black did not play g6 so here
the threat is just Bishop captures if
you allow that it's game over
so what can you play do the play tonight
captures any eight and here
graves we did not recapture as you might
think but rather he played Knight to d7
and it was in this position unmoved 32
that young sheet of do that resigned the
game and guruship equalizes the match
they go into the shoulder rapid
tiebreaks
which is a very exciting stuff so here
you don't have a move the point is that
Queen captures an e a fall by Queen
captures on f8 mate is coming and
there's nothing black can do to prevent
this there literally nothing you could
you could prevent mate with h6 but
that's just allows the Queen captures
here and whatever you do Queen captures
here comes your gonna be you're gonna be
down down a piece so and you're gonna
get made it very quickly so very
exciting stuff and I was very impressed
with this with this whole maneuver
Bishop to b7 winning the tempo then
Bishop the c6 then the ship - it just
wow
it really really awesome stuff very
shocked so very exciting that he was
able to equalize and we'll see what
happens in the shorter time controls I
just do hope you're still enjoying the
coverage so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
James Dunn henry Campbell our pewter
Skowronski goku g and tyler Morgan for a
contributor to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon most definitely continuing the
coverage of the Fida grand prix checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and so
on so thank you I will see you soon and
keep enjoying your excellent Sunday
season